the rectangle below has an area of 12x
to the fourth plus 6x to the third plus
15x squared square meters and we can see
the area right over here and they broke
it up this green area is 12x to the
fourth this purple area is 6x to the
third this blue area is 15x squared you
add them all together you get this
entire rectangle which would be the
combined areas 12x to the 4th plus 6x to
the third plus 15x squared
the length of the rectangle in meters so
this is the length right over here that
we're talking about so we're talking
about this distance
the length of the rectangle in meters is
equal to the greatest common monomial
factor of 12x to the fourth 6x to the
third
and 15
x squared what is the length and width
of the rectangle i encourage you to
pause the video and try to think try to
work through it on your own
well the key realization here is that
the length times the width the length
times the width is going to be equal to
this area and if the length is the
greatest common monomial factor of these
terms of 12x to the fourth 6x third and
15x squared well then we can factor that
out and then what we have left over is
going to be is going to be the width so
let's figure out what is the greatest
common monomial factor of these of these
three of these three terms and the first
thing we can look at is let's look at
the coefficients let's figure out what's
the greatest common factor of 12
6
and
15.
and there's a couple of ways you could
do it you could do it by looking at a
prime factorization you could say all
right well 12 is
2 times six which is two times
three that's the prime factorization of
twelve prime factorization of six is
just two times three
prime factorization of fifteen
is
three times five
and so the greatest common factor the
the largest the largest factor that's
divisible into all of them so let's say
we can throw a
we can throw a 3 in there
3 is divisible into
all of them
and that's it because we can't say a 3
and a 2 a 3 and a 2 would be divisible
into 12 and 6 but there's no 2 that's
divisible into 15 and we can't see a 3
and a 5 because 5 isn't divisible into
12 or 6. so the greatest common factor
is going to be 3. another way we could
have done this is we could said what are
the
non-prime factors of each of these
numbers 12 you could have said okay i
can get 12 by saying 1 times 12
or
2 times 6
or 3 times 4
6 you could have said let's see that
could be 1 times 6 or 2 times 3
so those are the factors of 6 and then
15 you could have said well 1 times 15
or
3 times 5. and so you say the greatest
common factor well 3 is the is the
largest number that i've listed here
that is common to all three of these
factors so once again the greatest
common
the greatest common factor of 12 6 and
15 is 3. so we're looking at the
greatest common monomial factor the
coefficient is going to be three
and then we look at these powers of x we
have x to the fourth
we have x to the i'm just in a different
color
we have
x to the fourth x to the third and x
squared well what's the largest power of
x that's divisible into all of those
well it's going to be x squared x
squared is divisible into x to the
fourth and x to the third and of course
x squared itself so the greatest common
monomial factor is 3x squared this
length right over here
this is 3 x squared
so this is 3x squared we can then figure
out what the width is
so what's if we
if we were to divide 12x to the fourth
by 3x squared what do we get well 12
divided by 3 is
4
and x to the 4th divided by x squared is
x squared notice 3x squared times 4x
squared is 12x to the 4th
and then we move over to this purple
section if we take 6x to the third
divided by 3x squared
6 divided by 3 is 2
and then x to the third divided by x
squared is just going to be x
and then last but not least
we have
15 divided by 3 is going to be 5
x squared divided by x squared is just 1
so it's just going to be 5. so the width
is going to be 4x squared plus 2x
plus 5.
so once again the length we figure that
out is the greatest common monomial
factor of these terms is 3
x squared and the width is 4
x squared plus 2 x
plus 5. and one way to think about it is
we just factored we just factored this
expression over here we could write we
could write
that actually i want to see the original
thing we could write that 3 x squared
times
4 x squared plus two x plus five
which is the entire width well that's
going to be equal to the area that's
going to be equal to our original
expression 12x to the fourth power plus
6x to the third plus 15 x squared